isabelle famille anne serre dans ses
bras à celui qui est devenu un ami
personnel
les policiers qui a transporté d'urgence
le froid qu'elle attendait depuis deux
ans et environ deux mois elle vivait
encore avec un foie dysfonctionnelle
elle était à la croisée des chemins
elle s'était résignée à mourir j'ai eu
deux sections du fois j'ai eu mon dieu
des conduits qui ont été comme refait
pour contourner des voies biliaires je
me suis dit ah titre c'est fini
merci à tout le monde les merci la vie
de m'avoir permis de vivre pendant 45
ans les médecins ont toujours soupçonné
qu'isabelle souffrait d'une colère j'ai
aux hépatites depuis l'adolescence
résultat la formation à répétition de
pierres dans les voies biliaires deux
fois sacrée des lésions en passant dans
les petites mini voies biliaires et
basse moment le sacré des ouvertures et
les bactéries qu'on a naturellement dans
le corps remonte dans ces lésions l'eau
s'infiltre dans le sang durant ces 22
mois d'attentes
isabelle a milité pour adopter le
consentement présumé après celles qui
existent déjà dans 27 pays pour réduire
les listes d'attentes une personne qui
décède et présumé consentante ou
prélèvement de ses organes
à moins qu'elle ne refusent pas et qui
de son vivant
la directrice de la maison des greffés
du québec croit que le gouvernement
devrait étudier la question
isabelle est la preuve vivante de
bénéfices du don d'organes est épanouie
et heureuse
puis alors un sentiment de bonheur et de
la pensée aussi pour son donateur passe
y avait pas eu ce donc là bas serait pas
là aujourd'hui
la femme dans la quarantaine était minot
supprimés et devra être prudente pendant
trois mois
mais le meilleur reste à venir j'ai
vraiment envie de craquer dans la vie
humaine l'année 2019 symbolisera un
nouveau départ pour cette survivante ici
pascal ruedin radio canada montréal
comme m